hey ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
lobby gamespot sweetly show about video
games people talking about video games
and all sorts of other fun hi I'm Chris
waters I'm standing in for Daniel Dwyer
he is traveling the world or somesuch
off on a vacation before gamescom next
week but this week we've got news about
games we got debates about games and
we've got two guys on couch then I'm
gonna introduce right now Andy Baumann
game Decker what's up guys hey are you
doing I'm doing well we're here to talk
about mafia three because mafia three
was announced this morning even though
like it's kind of been rumored for like
years now yeah we know what do you want
to know about mafia I want to know what
you want in mafia Andy I want to know
next week we're gonna be getting more
information about it but until then like
you guys have played some mafia
significant amounts what do you want
from this it's coming back after five
years I kind of left mafia to feeling
like all right that's enough cool I did
the mob we did the mafia thing nailed it
we nailed it we got it mafia one came
out of nowhere it was amazing it was
absolutely brilliant the city was alive
like in a way that even now games have a
struggle like getting at cuz it things
like cops a pulley over speeding like
you had to live in that world you had to
amend you a traffic laws or suffer the
consequences and you get like ride on
the L train and like goat it's like
you're going to work or whatever and
then it's like oh now you gotta like
caps of duty Duke run and do crimes and
that's because you fell in the wrong
crowd whatever like it so it felt it had
this cool feeling of it and also maybe I
was younger and and more susceptible to
it well that was 2002 yeah as a while
ago so we're seeing greg saavn in his
video review with the baseball and then
2010 eight years later mafia two came
out and it was alright it's very highly
reviewed by kevin van Horten really wait
five Wow okay it was more of like a
shooter than the first game as far as
like you had cover mechanics and you
could you know blast dudes with an array
of guns and you know if it was alright
so i had to drive in the city but it
just didn't feel quite as our
revolutionary as the first one did yeah
like the city of mafia two it was it was
cool it looked cool but there wasn't
much in there it almost felt like a
linear game
even though it was in a big city and I
think like why is this an open world
exactly that was kind of my question
even carried over to the end like once
you finish the game I believe that was
it right like you couldn't go back in
the world in free roam unless you wanted
to start a new game so do you think like
so there's the question of open world
versus linear right i mean you know if
you're going to have an open world you
got to kind of do something with it
otherwise it's just so much space for
you to traverse on your way and possibly
get busted by cops with like really
terribly handling cars from yeah yeah
you like try to drift there get points
for drifting i guess like whatever you
get points for drifting in a car from
the 50s there's a whole bunch of weird
details in acting like i remember you
could like go home and like drink beer
from the fridge oh yeah like that it was
like and there's playboys yeah just like
scattered around there's the collectible
right you'd let go around the city and
try to pick up the answer I would like
try and find out like I'm gonna like a
grown-ass man who can just go into a
store or and buy some you haven't always
find it in a garbage can not to dwell
too much but these are like from the era
well that was a cool so that was another
thing the period sort of accuracy about
mafia has always been like a real strong
suit yeah and you know in terms of the
cars the outfits the sort of the music
the way that the world is constructed
these little details so if we're looking
at mafia now what kind of time period
would you want to see it in so yeah they
they should tear it all down and start
over right uh-huh because we've done
this mob thing italian-made men yeah I
don't wanna be like in new york city
again yeah it's like I want something
more I want something different so we
were joking early like what if they made
it like it's still called mafia but what
if it's just like the modern drug game
yeah and it's like cartel body morsing
Maryland or whatever oh the wire yeah
murder Lynn it's the wire whatever no
that'd be cool like if it's but it's
probably not gonna be that but sure
maybe they just take the setting
somewhere else where there is no there's
never been a mob movie in
I don't know Louisiana Louisiana yeah
that's one of the rumors that's been
going around and they teased an image
sort of released today that had you do
see some Spanish moss on the trees there
on the sides and you see some cars that
look like uh I'm not I'm no I'm no car
ologist but that's like 70 esque right i
mean we're past the 50s maybe 60s 70s
it's sort you see for people they're
lined up I think one of them is a woman
and the others appear to be dudes so
character has been another like real
strong suit in mafia historically that
writing and the way they sort of you
know it's it's an interesting story and
so you know don't yeah it gets real
elaborate into there's like different
mobs on mobs killing people that you
want to save and then you got to like
help them and then everybody dies and
someone's an FBI informant and then
you're maybe gonna die and fade to black
what at what point do you become a
schoolteacher and or a dock worker and
just lament the failing infrastructure
of the city that you live yeah I don't
hopefully from soon hopefully this is
gonna happen no I to story I mean it
almost kind of felt like a Scorsese
video game sort of just the way it was
set up I mean it wasn't was on the same
level mm-hm but I mean I'd like to see
something again like that like focus
more on storytelling once again if it is
in the what's it called the Louisiana
area if it's in the bayou that does seem
to be pulling from like the first season
of True detective like that just feeling
and that storytelling and I think games
these kind of games have always liked
pulled from movies like Scorsese you
know that's like yeah they want to keep
going with those threads and like yeah
so because there's definitely a
different flavor to like that kind of
fast pace New York like a very Italian
influence sort of new gangster ethos and
then like this sort of may be slower
southern pace of just like you know like
the days are drawn out in this
suffocating heat and like there's a lot
more sort of rural spaces involved black
feel like yeah there's like this
Caribbean influence in there too so it
is you know they're definitely cinematic
tradition and of course like with TV
with your detective something for them
to draw on and I think that's been a
strength of mafia in the past and i
think the cool thing about the louisiana
setting if that is the case it's not
something you typically see in games the
last time i think i was in Louisiana and
game in a game was like tony hawk's
underground or something like that like
yeah it's left 4 dead 2 somewhere oh
there was some latter-day runs well and
also in battlefield hardline there's a
swamp scene but that's like my am that's
Florida somewhere but I was like a fan
boat you know going through the swamp
but having a live open world day I think
I think could be a really really strong
feature for the game hopefully set it
apart from you know like Grand Theft
Auto and these other sort of for
bringing to life a different kind of
city a different feel and yeah mafia 3
announced today gonna be learning more
about mafia 3 at Gamescom next week on
wednesday i believe the fifth their
trailer dropping oh yeah so there's like
the whole like thing is gonna setting
probably trailer big thing coming out of
games common next week let us know what
you think about mafia 3 in the comments
below what you want to see Andy Jake
thank you guys so much dude thanks for
having yeah good stuff right all right
folks Lost Horizon to the gamescom
trailers are already coming here's one
for Lost Horizon to check it out
you
if you thought there were no games
coming out this summer you are wrong and
you're not playing rocket League which
you really should be doing but out this
week it's King's Quest the first chapter
in the new episodic series by the odd
gentlemen and Sierra join me on the
couch Mary Kish and Jeremy Jane to
Questers of kings you guys have play
that game yes if you like done the whole
first episode almost we're both really
close uh well Mary I don't I haven't
been that I'm yeah we're about like
three fourths the way it's actually
longer than I thought it would be which
I was pleasantly surprised considering
that this is an episodic adventure we
were wondering how long they would be a
couple hours but it's about a good five
hour play true i would say for the first
chapter give or take and that's a great
amount of time for the price point that
they're they're selling it's ten dollars
and it's but its way longer than i
thought like I i was talking to Mary
yesterday I was playing it for the first
time and I was like oh yeah I'm like
almost done and then she went home and
played it it was like oh you're like at
the beginning you know oh yeah Jeremy so
ten dollars a pop or forty bucks for the
season pass of five pretty standard
adventure sort of telltale press pricing
model we're going to talk about your
guys experience with the game we're
going to like soft-pedal it on the
spoilers obviously haven't finished it
and we know that a lot of you guys are
gonna be wanted to check it out too so
it's going to be pretty spoiler free but
want to talk about like like how you're
feeling about it so far our review is
coming this week but from you guys to
people who have played it you have
different history with the King's Quest
series Mary what's your perspective on
this one right we were talking about
this Jeremy's fresh to the series and
I've played several King's Quest is
actually one of the very first games my
father ever bought for me on PC was
King's Quest seven and it was just this
wonderful magical point-and-click
adventure and I have a lot of wonderful
memories attributed to the King's Quest
series this is like one of the best
parts there's like a mom and a daughter
they're both looking for each other and
this is so standard you're gonna see a
lot of things that you'll actually see
in the current King's Quest kind of
resurfaced the same humor
character-driven story you'll see a lot
of items it's really amazing how many
items you get and similar in the new one
there's about five different puzzles
going on at once here sir no it's not
near in this direct sense where your
euro only you will know exactly what
you're supposed to be doing next one get
the thing you use the thing you get
another thing you use that thing that's
not how a lot of times you you're not
really sure exactly what you're getting
all these items for and they're not to
be used for much later so in this one
this is the kind of puzzle where you
needed to find an items that you get to
that pathway and the this King's Quest
it does a very similar thing where you
actually can't get to the next area
until you've found a very particular
item something that they tease to you
and the game does an excellent way of
giving you a lot of clues so there's
more than enough hints along the way so
you're like oh I'm supposed to use this
to get through that bush like that I saw
a long time ago so that I can get to a
well it's all it's all very well done in
the storyline there was almost no time
in this playthrough so far where I've
been like wow nowhere to go by the other
you know the other side of that coin of
course is have there been times when
it's been just so obvious at every turn
that you know where to go that you're
kind of like wit well let me figure
something out here stop giving me so
much information honestly it's so it's
it's a pretty easy game like I feel like
it's like family friendly I don't think
kids would play it and figure it out or
anything but I think like a younger kid
with their parent alongside would not
have too much of a difficult time
playing through but you know the other
side of the coin is there were
definitely times where I was like oh
whoa this puzzle is like deceivingly
difficult like there were times where it
got a little more complex on me than I
thought it was going to mm-hmm and
that's one of the things I like most
about King's Quest and again you know
for people who missed that I haven't
played any of the King's Quest games I'm
familiar with them I've seen them play
it I've never played any of them but
this particular one the new one had this
thing going on where it was sort of like
it would be very like disney-esque and
family friendly and the animation is all
like hand-painted environments and stuff
it reminded me of me no kuni a lot
visually but behind it you know it's not
a kids game like there were things going
on and I'm not gonna spoil anything but
you know there are characters who died
unexpectedly and I was like oh my god
and I was like emotionally there was an
emotional toll taken by this death I was
like it was like a five-year-old kid I
think this would be devastated be a
little upsetting yeah but it does have
that fantastical sort of Disney quality
to it and it is very like just like
magical and like fantasy driven but it
gets down to business there's some real
stuff going on it's interesting because
the whole conceit is that you
like you're playing out these memories
of the king he's talking he's telling
this to his granddaughter and so like
right from the beginning it does sort of
set up that family dynamic the dynamic
of you know Papa Kish and Mary Kish like
sitting down and check it out King's
Quest seven pinkish it makes you feel
feel feels there's there's times where
and acting is just incredibly so much
better for the record for any other
kings quest game you'd be like the
writing is pretty good like the acting
questionable but i'm gonna let it slide
yeah it's really good it's a long way
it's christopher lloyd from Back to the
Future is king Graham old King Graham
but they have a lot of the same like the
sudden these are like these ridiculously
silly characters they do a really good
job this is they're playing they're
paying homage to like old comedy series
you'll definitely see pieces of like the
Knights of newman hair like you and all
sorts of really cool witty banter from
characters that I don't even know if
they have any value later on but that's
something that they're known for is that
you'll you'll hear a story that might
have nothing to do with anything but
it's entertaining and it's enjoyable to
hear I've had such a great time so far
and I really really have liked this game
and so you've been sort of queued up to
expect a certain degree of that whimsy
right of that sort of being punny of it
referencing you know fantasy tropes and
like like it's almost you know there's a
lot of winks to you know you're also
acknowledging that there's a player
playing the game you know Jeremy I'm
wondering how that struck you like in
terms of sort of the overall tone
balancing humor with you no more sort of
dramatic moments so there's a lot of
good sort of like meta humor like you
say it acknowledges that you're playing
a game and so you know for example
there's one thing where there's like two
levers and you have to pick one and
there's no indication of which one you
should pick there's no like hints or
anything it's just 50-50 chance and so
the first time I tried it and I got it
wrong and you know I won't spoil
anything but something unfortunate
happens to the player and actually they
show it in the trailer oh it's like the
first decision you make and also ready
to say there's a skeleton crushed by a
thing next to the one that crushes is
there you doing extremely unobservant I
was doing a speedrun Chris no just
King's Quest done quick um but anyway
other than that glaringly obvious hint
is
hey you know if you are crushed and it
cuts back to old King Graham and
Gwendolyn and he goes and that's what
would have happened if I pulled the left
switch but right but I'm here so
obviously that's not bad so every time
you die in the game it'll like create
some sort of like elaborate narrative
loophole and it's like oh but that's not
what happened my favorite one of those
is you get a hatchet at some point and
you know in adventure eating like this
you're pointing like you're like trying
the hatchet let me just like this you're
putting on people or anything that's the
best part is like so I tried it on one
of the other nights and and you see
Graham like wind up with it and
gwendolyn's like a new you and you cut
him and she gave Graham is like oh no I
didn't do that at all like I couldn't
use the hatchet there that would have
been wrong but it's it's like it plays
all the fact that like on pointing
clicks are trying to use everything on
everything and it definitely doesn't
have an abundance of like like it's it's
clear enough without giving it away that
you never feel like you're like oh I
guess I'll just walk around hatchet in
everything till I figure this out mm-hmm
all right well this is episode 1 right
and so you know it's sort of it has the
task of not just introducing you to what
kind of game they want to be you know
immersing you in the style and
introducing characters but also of like
setting a sort of arc or hinting at
what's to come and you guys had not
quite made it to the end and you know we
want to keep it vague but like do you
feel so far that there's this is sort of
a good kickoff for the for the series
yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm happy with
what I've seen so far I expect that a
lot of these items will come back in the
future previous Kings quests if you you
saw a character that you loved and maybe
you left them and they were angry with
you or something like that that could
end up coming back for chapters from now
and impacting you it's it's interesting
where you you have no idea yet it's very
early on I'm not really sure they're
setting up a lot of this live-action
story right here to with this girl and
her her grandfather so you're not really
sure exactly where all these characters
in the story arc is going to go yet but
i already have anticipated recurring
characters things that will probably
come back and and I'm I'm really just
excited to see what's
but it's a little too soon to make that
call yeah I'm I there are a lot of
choices you make and I'm very hopeful
that the future chapters will hearken
back to that a lot like I hope that
because some of the choices are clearly
just like it'll change the story a
little bit but it won't impact like that
rippling change of like you killed that
dude well guess what you can't do this
whole thing it's not like a life is
strange or any of those other as far as
I'm aware where if you make a decision
Alexa was telling me that if you make a
decision in life is change episode like
to you actually just miss a whole
section also three and this doesn't seem
the same thing so Jeremy I'm I on
purpose yeah chose different things to
see what the impact would be and there's
this part we have to like find a wheel I
found one from one shop and he found it
from another it made 0 different it was
just a choice came back together I
really do hope that some of those
choices do have more rippling there's
another larger decision with a dragon
later where we both shows different
things and it did have a different
impact so at that stage I'm not entirely
sure if later down the road if if you
know if you take down the dragon or if
you help him like how loose now Jack
dragon helped me so those are things
that we just don't know yet but it's
exciting to see how far they're going to
take will the dragon remember that in
the parlance of gelatin so I hope he
does all right Mary Jeremy thanks for
coming on talking about Kings quests or
a night to remember it isn't it is and
it's recommended i do recommend it for
as much as though plated it's super
great value for ten bucks me sane we
don't have a review on the site yeah i
do know it's like really soon it's
already in and it's like up for Q&A so
it should be here really soon but until
then Mary kiss recommends it Jerry and I
recommend it it's really cool and it's
fun delightful very cool our kings quest
review will be up shortly it's out now
on steam and consoles consoles consoles
it's coming to consoles it's maybe not
out of ghazals now shouldn't done my
research there's a PlayStation but not
xbox yet you're Amish on consoles so the
Xbox a hundred percent and ps4 code
didn't work but I think it is going to
be working too yeah yeah cool King's
Quest a night to remember alright guys
we've got a debate coming up because the
fall is bringing the return of the
rhythm Titans guitar hero and rockband
will be talking about that in just a
moment but before we do that
going to take a look at a trailer for
WWE 2k16 and even if you're not a
wrestling fan if you haven't heard this
news there's a very strange very
intriguing new character making it in to
the wrestling ring when this game comes
out check it out
you
I need you close your boots eat your
motorcycle you forgot to say please
Wow stone cold vs The Terminator can't
wait for it all right ah this fall we've
got the rock band games the guitar hero
games they're all coming back in a big
way guitar hero live versus rock band 4
we are here to check in on which one is
leading the pack in sort of the
midsummer stretch enroute to fall
release Mike my hardy and Justin hey
Walt thank you guys for joining me
thanks for having us guys a couple
couple of plastic rock superstars over
here from what I've seen you might say
that I I mean I've toured the world the
living rooms fans like the basement
billions all around I'm a rug gun you
might say he got the chance to play some
guitar hero live last week they brought
it by and got to strum away it was my
first time with the new guitar very cool
sort of you know three three and three
buttons as opposed to five right in a
row and I think that sort of as this as
the release of these games is starts to
loom closer and closer it's the old
rivalry is back guitar hero rock band
that's what people are one like that's
the question that you're wanted like
which is the one that I'm going to get
because it's expensive prospect to like
not only get the game to get more of
these plastic instruments to take up the
room in your your living room mhm like
is it gonna be worth it to reinvest in
rock band is it worth it to get this new
guitar in it it's too early to say
definitively like this game is better
than that game you spent so little time
with both of them but I we definitely
have an idea of where we're at so far
based on what we played yeah so let's
talk about what we do know we know
guitar hero has a new guitar Mike do you
think that is a the case for guitar hero
or against it it's definitely case for I
like you recently just got my first
hands-on time with it and I really like
it it was kind of weird because I was
really looking for a new reason to get
back into guitar hero specifically
because that was definitely that kind of
fell into second place for me back when
I was still playing rhythm games i loved
rock band but i grew up on guitar hero
so being able to have like it's kind of
like two strings now almost because you
can do frets you do frets on the older
ones too but it was still wasn't i guess
it's more realistic in a way but I'm the
classic to string guitar yeah yeah so it
was it took a little while to get used
to
do I mean you seem to you guys are both
seemed to grab it right away it's a
novel experience I mean it's cuz it's
not just a single button but there's two
rows of buttons and so you have to work
with sort of different elevations of
your fingers and yeah you get that like
familiar cramping when you're like
trying something really hard with your
hand for the first time it doesn't work
out so well but then you get the hang of
it and so Justin do you feel like it's a
the novelty of that play experience or
Mike do you feel like that's a powerful
draw yeah that's one of the things that
I've always loved about those games like
I've played guitar hero since before
there was guitar hero when it was that
you know the different beatmania games
from Konami and like this game came out
I did think would live up to it guitar
hero was amazing and just every
iteration of that game that challenge to
make yourself even better on guitar and
like this takes it like it makes your
brain think in a different way and like
that's a lot of fun like i want to take
on this challenge and the way that
they've kind of set it up in the game
makes it feel like it's gonna let you
play against other people in a way
that's gonna challenge you to keep going
you're going to go to see people's
leaderboards and scores on the left hand
side of the screen and no like I i can
do that a little bit better I can aim to
get a better score on that and not only
getting a better score but with a
different set of challenges said like I
want that challenge and I like I want
something new and different about that
that competitiveness has always sort of
been where guitar hero excels is you
know the really tough fingering they're
really like difficult songs and people
striving to master them to me has sort
of been my guitar hero experience rock
band on the other hand has generally
been more of a social experience you get
more people playing at the same time and
the question here I guess one of them is
certainly one of hardware because if you
buy guitar hero live you're going to
need to buy the game and the hardware
it's going to cost you a significant
amount but harmonics currently working
to make sure rock band peripherals from
the past are usable in rock band 4 how
do we think that's going to affect rock
band 4 negatively or positively well so
I think it's going to be about a hundred
dollars i think is what they're aiming
for for the new guitar hero with the
guitar and probably more expensive for
if you need to get some of these new
instruments they're letting you use your
old instruments but i know talking with
the harmonic skies and mad catz that
they are going to have a new set of
instrument
for the new set of abilities like
they're very similar to what we've
played before but they are better and
like if I play the game i'm probably
going to want the to upgrade my
instruments as well like that's another
at least a hundred dollars you're not
gonna call the old guitars out of
storage like that's part of the appeal
for me is I already have this stuff it's
going to be more accessible to not the
rock band guitars those are those are my
least favorite guitars like guitar hero
has always had better hardware like it
in rock band you have the the the strum
that doesn't quite click like I never
liked that the buttons are always mushy
they don't seem to last as long guitar
heroes bet I've always used my guitar
hero guitar but uh playing a little bit
with the new rock band intruments like
they're they're better to higher quality
but is that really enough like the thing
the thing that is that it's it is like
you said a social experience and that's
the thing that's more fun and that's I
think what's missing from Guitar Hero
like I love being able to do that but
whether I have to buy new instruments or
not I want to have all of those
different experiences and let my friends
be able to play drums or sing and only
playing guitar is I don't know if that's
enough yeah I mean especially after you
know basically being spoiled by rock
band thing of three part vocal harmonies
guitars keyboard drums I mean you know
keyboards not coming back for rock band
4 but drums guitars harmonies I imagine
they all are well so there's not going
to be a keyboard in the next rock man
that's the only thing that they're
cutting out integrally right did I
that's what I was trying to say but good
clarification I'm not sure if I actually
said that but rock band yeah there's
that social dynamic so Mike you said you
were sort of you know you start got your
start with guitar hero but then you
swung towards rock band was it that
social impetus that put you there yeah
definitely I think it was the feeling of
actually kind of being part of a band I
mean I used to when I was very young say
I was in a band but don't ever listen to
us if you somehow find us because we
weren't good but I will rob your band
again I yeah so just the that feeling of
you know what your friends playing drums
you're playing guitar you feel like
you're contributing to a song was
awesome and I think it was very much and
like a great you know innovation on the
party rhythm based game and I think
that's definitely an impetus for me to
get back in a rock band because guitar
hero has again been that competitive
pole for me although you know with
guitar hero TV and whatnot the music vid
Oh stuff it seems like it could be Oh
make it a little more accessible and
make it like social something you just
jump into a parties and whatnot well
that's the wild card in this it's how
they're gonna do music so rock band I
have a ridiculous library of songs that
I download it and I never really got
into that guitar hero but at the same
time in rock and guitar hero that you're
gonna have access to music from the very
beginning that's kind of like a music
channel and like that's kind of
appealing like is someone who switched
over to things like Spotify and like
that's how I discover music is just like
well I'm just going to turn on this
radio basically and listen to stuff
being able to watch music videos and so
like here's music that's being offered
you and it's constantly new which guitar
here is going to offer and hopefully
well I mean out of the box it's going to
be free for a guitar hero TV there's
going to be some pricing for individual
songs after that but that amount of lots
of content for free is its kind of
appealing and I yeah oh sorry I feel
like yeah guitar hero TV specifically
more so than live is something perfect
that they're on in a party because it is
like I think it's a little more
accessible it's more recognizable to
people than just the 3d character
animations from the past rock band and
Guitar Hero yeah the fact that you can
just have these music videos playing and
again like Justin said it is random it's
like visually interesting too I mean and
even if you know and guitar hero five
you were you could play a party mode
that allowed you to just drop out of
guitar and then it would be like this it
would play just a you know there's no
note highway you're just playing a music
video so it can the social and like it
sort of allows for the ebb and flow of a
social situation as opposed to I think
the pitfall that they were trying to you
know one of things they're trying to
avoid is that like okay like what song
do you want to play next that scroll
Scroll scroll yeah well I play this one
no I don't want play dota 2 all we just
played that one yeah but I really want
to you know that selection process like
for people who you know played a fair
amount of rock band and Guitar here in
the past like that's a big party
experience Guitar Hero TV taking a shot
at trying to undermine that I mean it
goes either way like it's for my group
who was always the singers choice and
like we would just rotate through all
the instruments from the singer gets up
to the mic they get to choose the song
get to pick something you want to sing
and taking that away like I mean there's
no vocals so like it's just a guitar
game anyway mm-hmm but at the same time
like I love being able to sing along
with something and like that's part of
that rocking out
perience for meats it's not just playing
a fake guitar it's that whole cohesive
thing yeah there's that performance
aspect yeah you to be clear you can
still be that weird person in the corner
singing a lot but there will shake
anyway it's gonna happen it no one's
gonna be scoring you on that if you
unless you get the three weird other
people the panel of judges with you know
their numbers and they sort of get used
you're a little guitar hero Idol going
on right that's uh you know DLC plan you
can maybe push this all right so guitar
hero live slated for october 10th rock
band 4 for october sixth october is
going to be when you know this all
shakes out and we start to see which
one's gain momentum but as of now you
know we're we're almost in early august
who do you think is sort of in the lead
guitar hero rock band personally which
one you're gravitating towards I'm gonna
have to go rock band 4 but only by a
little mm-hmm the hardware is compelling
in guitar hero but rock band has all the
things that I already know what love and
being able to sing is a really big part
I like being able to customize my band
like I like having my little character
and I have the stupid hat and the custom
guitar that unlocked it's it's pretty
neat it's I like it it's cool I got all
these stickers on my plastic eggs I had
my own band when you know playing rock
band they were less sexually androgynous
hydrangeas that's a mouthful yeah it's
also gonna be my real band's name once I
look I I know this carries over right
like guitar hero will carry directly
over to playing wheel guitar yeah from
two strings to six strings it's just a
totally small leaf no big deal all right
Mike Justin thank you guys for coming on
talking about guitar hero and rockband
folks chiming in the comments and let us
know what you think which one are you
leaning towards which one you think has
a better campaign so far and I guess
we'll all see how it shakes out coming
this October all right guys just one
more nutin out of business before we go
away here and ask you to be our hand
models here don't take these out of the
box just hold them but wouldn't they be
worth more if we you know if you've got
your grubby fingers all over them know
Justin they would oh they got my face my
face oils check it out Oh Mary's giving
us the okay to open it up Mike make a
move all right take out your Gunners
because we're giving away some gunner
glasses
heroes of the storm branded for you
folks try the Mater home yeah put them
on these guys are design you guys have
seen these before right gunner oh yeah
oh yeah designed to like reduce the
fatigue and also make you looks like you
have jaundice eyes or maybe you just
came from a shooting range anyways we're
giving these things away you guys want
to win these there's going to be a URL
up on screen that you can follow to
enter to win oh man look at those I
acrobatics my hearty nice work let's get
that up on screen and when you guys
kidnap totally enter two way there it is
gamespot com watch heroes dash dash the
dash storm dash giveaway I don't know
why I said that out loud you should have
just read it it's way better anyways
thanks to the folks at gunner and here's
the storm for providing these for us to
give away and thank you guys for
watching good luck entering contests and
we'll see you next week on the lobby
with gamescom news galore and maybe even
some more fancy I maneuvers
you